everyone so thank you very much for
being here before we started just trying
to also action on holiday this week
basically so house collecting data as
you can see yesterday and I brought you
all poll bonus which is a Spanish
dessert so please help yourself at the
break this so I guess everyone has an
account I installed is anyone because
anyone struggle to use anaconda or is
everyone familiar with it okay if anyone
has a problem please raise your hand and
either someone around your I'll come
help you so you have my contact details
here please don't hesitate to reach out
there's anything I can assist you with
and I wanted us to before we dig into
the data set I wanted us to start by
asking why you know like why are we all
here why are we interested in this why
you have this in common and I'm telling
how I fell in love with statistics so
all the undergraduate student of that
was in London many years ago and I was
applying I took I started taking applied
statistics courses and I don't know with
it because I realized that it's very
similar to languages which I always love
so you have this world of data basically
and statistics is the language that
allows you to interpret that world
so either you speak it or you don't but
if you don't there's a whole world
that's going to be close to you so it's
from an applied point of view I think
it's an amazing skill set to have then
why does why should we focus on data so
as you all know it's one of the most
interesting professions at the moment we
estimate that there's going to be
200,000 people lacking in this
discipline over the next couple of years
and the reason I think it's fantastic
that you're all here is because
obviously you're the best position to
take advantage of this over the next two
three four years so those disco tation
from erik von stein who's a fellow at
Oxford and at the same time he's an MD
and Peter steals capital fund and she
said it's better to be in an expanding
world and not quite in exactly the right
field than to be in a contracting world
where people's worst behavior comes out
so I think hearing the data world were
in an ever-expanding universe at the
moment is the expansion is not going to
stop and I know that we all have very
diverse skill sets and this is part of
what made what makes this build so
vibrant at the moment that people would
such diverse backgrounds are coming into
it learning a common language and then
doing quite quite interesting things
with it obviously then why did I take a
healthcare data set for today I think
health care is is a bit relegated
so it's underappreciated as a field how
many people here for example would have
known that thirty percent of the world's
data is healthcare data so it's it's a
huge field and we don't give it the
attention it deserves and then I have
this quotation from Scott Jagger who set
up the data program at Johns Hopkins
with these colleagues obviously who said
the biomedical scientists have been the
pillar of the healthcare system for the
past century now in the 21st century the
healthcare system is going to have to
equal pillars the biomedical sciences
and the data Sciences so it's really a
fantastic field to start looking at at
the moment next what are we going to go
over today so as I said in conductor is
statistical data analysis tutorial so
what I try to create here is a blueprint
for how you'd approach a data set for
the first time so obviously you write a
report about your data set before moving
forward basically with the analysis with
more sophisticated modeling and
obviously going towards your conclusion
so what is this first part of a report
that you do when you start just a data
project no matter where it's in business
or in academia how do you start
approaching it from the beginning and
what tools you use and in an age when
everyone wants to do deep learning which
is fantastic obviously I think sometimes
it's good to also go over the basics
again because you realize that actually
you forget them pretty quickly in terms
of packages that we're going to use
they're all part of anaconda so you
should have any problems uploading them
so panda is obviously numpy Seabourn for
visualization I import methyl blip here
as well and then we're going to use
stats models the step total package for
for statistical analysis I give it a
naught is the wrong familiar here with
pandas in Python or should i comment the
code as well here and there is that a
yes is that a No
okay so we'll do a bit of both and
hopefully it'll be your biggest for
everyone so Matt go bleep in line
obviously means that your breasts are
going to be shown within your code you
know in your Jupiter notebook and that's
obviously quite a useful option then I
give another a seaborne of option here
as well obviously this is entirely up to
you I want to first to thank the people
who collected this data so all the
credits are here it's it was done at
four institutes across the world so
hungry switzerland and then two in the
US and i wanted us to start by
remembering that your data management is
an integral part of your research
process so people are always very eager
to jump to the modeling site but
actually how you approach data
management is a core part of the project
you undertake and there are many
decisions that you need to make and that
will influence the whole subsequent
analysis they're going to do so let's
start by uploading the first data set
this is Cleveland so here we upload with
a PD three TSU function the process
Cleveland data text header none which
means that it should interpret the first
line of the file as a header is everyone
following okay perfect so here we get an
idea of the first ten observations in
this data set to see it's a numerical
tabular data set let's do the same with
Hungary so PD radius V processing gear
and data text here we see already that
we start having problems then let's do
the same with Switzerland and then let's
do the same with the VA data set which
is the last one the first and last one
here now that we uploaded each data set
individually let's concatenate them so
this is the P dot concat function so
Cleveland Hungary VA and Switzerland the
names we gave them and we concatenate
them vertically yes please yes
absolutely so you can put it wherever
you'd like obviously and you can grab it
from there
it's those four files that start to the
word processed so process VA data
process Switzerland data processing gear
and data and process click on data
please sorry
oh you need then just manually remove it
ok ok ok so it's all wrong with the
extension just manually turning to a jig
sticks extension
okay so let's slowly progress now that
we have the four data paths concatenated
into one large file let's name our
columns to make them more legible so DF
columns equals and then we give the list
of names for the columns that we want so
age sex chest pain rest BP cholesterol
fasting BS rest ECG max heart rate
exercise on G now ST depression slope
fury rasca P defect and then diagnosis
now let's look at the concatenated and
rename data set so we see every column
is numerical and the first questions
that we we ask ourselves is what sort of
study was this so is it an observational
or an experimental study in your opinion
yes
it's an observational study so how do
you know it's an observation or
experimental you ask whether the
explanatory variable was manipulated in
the course of the experiment and here
just by looking at the names of the
columns you can see that it was an
observational experiment which is very
common in the medical world for this
type of study in terms of what a true
experiment is so only one variable needs
to be manipulated we need to have a
control group and the observations so in
this case the patients need to be
randomized
which obviously here what was in the
case what is the quasi experiment
because the experiment is like a true
experiment but there's no random
assignment and obviously that makes a
huge difference the reason this is
important is because in an observational
study the regression line only describes
the data that you see it cannot be used
to describe an intervention it in that
experiment basically which was up in the
case with an experimental data set so
here we're just observing and we're
describing what we're observing
the second question is was it is it a
longitudinal or a cross-sectional study
in your opinion so here it's a
cross-sectional because longitudinal
means that you take the same observation
again the same patient in this case and
you measure them over time so the same
unit of of interest gets measured over
time that makes the longitudinal aspect
of the study here it's a cross-sectional
aspect patients who are taken over time
but that's what at one point each and
then you might want to go directly to
data analysis but I think it's so
important to remember that we always
start by doing background research it's
very rarely the case that you'll be the
first one to look at the datasets that
something will be so unique that no one
else has looked at it before so just
like in any research project in
particular in academia you start by
doing a meta study and you look for
people who've looked at the same problem
as you before and you try to learn what
they've done so here you find three
studies one by the Toronto won by
Sundaram and one by Sony so in the
Python notebook you'll have the full the
full websites obviously there's no need
for us to go there right now something
else I want to say is that it's very
important this was done by a study which
is we're looking at data collected by
doctors and what you often find in data
science is that people expect a lot from
the domain experts in this case the
doctors if we were working with them
right now I think it would be much more
up to us to make as many steps towards
them as possible in understanding those
variables for example you understand
what they mean medically and how they
work with them then we expect a day to
teach it to us I'm saying this because I
see it quite often and what happens is
that the more interesting or domain
expert is the more interesting the data
they have is and the more you want to
work with them but the less time they're
going to have to get you up to speed so
I think it's also as to the data
community to start making much more
inroads towards what we call domain
knowledge is basically and domain
experts in each in each field that you
look at so the first the first stage in
any data study in my opinion is the
exploratory data analysis right this is
what's going to answer our question of
what data do we have here how does it
behave like what structure does it have
what patterns does it have so then the
first point is the research which you
just mentioned then
organize and summarize the data then we
look for important features and patterns
then we look for exceptions perhaps and
then we interpret these findings and
this is what's going to be the
conclusion of our exploratory data
analysis the first part our tool or data
report so let's start looking at how
long is this data set so Len TS gives us
nine hundred twenty observations and
then Len DF columns gives us 14
variables that we have in the data set
so it's not a lot of variables what the
reason we start by doing this is because
you had that heuristic rule right of how
many you should have much more
observations than variables if possible
and a heuristic rule that's often given
it's five to one here we're at seventy
to one so we're safe from that point of
view obviously now what we need to do
before we can start working with pandas
with the data set we need to convert all
variables to numeric variables so we saw
that the draw its tabular numeric data
we need to tell pandas that this is what
it is so we need to take each variable
and use the PD to numeric function so
DSH we converted upon us to numeric we
take the original series in the data
frame and what errors equals scores does
this is an option that tells it to
interpret missing values as numpy dotn
and values instead of interpreting them
for example as empty strings so this is
a very useful function because it's
going to allow us to progress much
faster afterwards what this is the
longest block of code that we have and
we have to do it obviously so what I
suggest you do if you can is to take it
from the jupiter notebook that i passed
around both on USB key and that was part
of the two-year-old addresses if you can
and you just copy and paste if you don't
feel like retyping everything right now
one more option we've been using here is
for every categorical variable so all
our variables are numerical but when
they're also categorical we also need to
specify this for pandas so we we put
dots as type category
you
so the first question is missing values
which comes up I'm sure in every study
you undertake with data analyst has been
pre processed before and someone has
taken care of it or unless the people
who collected the data did an amazing
job but in the real world it's often
messier than that and the first question
is why why do we care so much about
missing values the problem is that
almost all statistical methods that we
use assume complete information about
the data so that you have so what what
missing data leads to is that parameter
estimates will be biased for example
statistical power of your results will
weaken and the precision of your
confidence interval will be diminished
as well so this is why we spend so much
time trying to deal with missing data
there there are three types of missing
variables the first one is missing
completely at random the second one is
missing at random and the third one is
not missing at random so this is all
expressed in terms of the probability
what is the probability of that value
missing at that place how is it linked
to the rest of your data set and that's
what determines if it's missing
completely at random or missing at
random or not missing at random if
missing at random this is important
because if it's missing at random your
missing data is ignoring the message is
missing it's ignorable and you don't
need to try to find that out if it's not
missing at random then clearly follow
the pattern and you need to spend a lot
of time finding out that what that
pattern is before you can start trying
to fill it or to deal with it what are
the standard options for dealing with
missing data so the first one is list
wise deletion so here we just remove
that observation the second one is
imputation so what you see most
frequently now in a blog for example or
in our tutorials is the mark the
marginal mean imputation so you replace
for example if you know column we have
missing values you just replace them
with the mean of that column then you
have a more sophisticated one which is
the conditional mean imputation so here
you replace them by doing the regression
model based on all the other variables
in your data set so that's a more robust
way of telling your missing values for a
variable and then you have more advanced
options like multiple imputation
maximum-likelihood ragin simulation and
then hot deck imputation which is a
particularly like unfortunately a very
few of these are supported by example SK
learns pre-processing impute method at
the moment so I know there's a lot of
work on that present you know more than
me there but very few of them are are
well supported like in other statistical
packages that's a place for pandas and
SK learn I guess are still progressing
I put three links here the second one is
very good so be you that edu marina take
report that's an amazing report
explaining what what missing data
represents how you should look at it and
giving you the detail of these more
advanced options for imputation and then
of course there's polar I took here a
quote quotation for Polaris and who says
that the only really good solution to
missing data is to not have any there's
no yeah it's unfortunately it's there's
nothing you can do by definition is
going to weaken your own your
statistical methods but you have to do
to deal with it then it was a poorly
done study and you can use that data
I'll be honest and and will actually see
something here so how do you check for
the missing data obviously we use the
pandas is no function so that's that's a
function that looks for missing values
for the number-9 values and then we give
it a value counts so that we see if
there's any true or false how many there
are the SH is no value counts and we see
that that for age it's false everywhere
so there's no missing values for for
this variable in our data set then I do
this for every variable I mean you have
to be xx is no value counts again we
have no missing variables this is
perfect then I'm looking at how many men
you have but we'll come back to this
later and in this section in short I'm
just looking at every variable every
coloring the dataset and I'm trying to
figure out if there are missing values
and if there are how many there are
so recipe P for example blood pressure
at rest you see that here we have
true so 5959 variables are missing 59
observations sorry are missing in it for
this variable but what you want to also
know ugly in way in this case when you
start finding missing values is what
what do they represent versus your data
set for example so here if you do a DFS
BP is no so you find all the missing
values then you count them and then you
divide them by the length of total
length of your data set you get the
percentages of missing values so here we
see that we have six point four percent
missing values for this variable
yes cholesterol we have a bit more we
have 30 D as fasting BS we have 90 and
what I want to do whatever I wanted to
point out here is that the standard
value counts method function ignores
missing values so see for example if we
just believe this if we didn't give it
the drug now equals true a parameter you
tell us that there's a here we have
around 69 we're round 830 values when we
know that we have 1920 so we just didn't
show them two hours to to us basically
that's why it's very important to start
dealing with the missing values before
you start analyzing your data set here
we have very few max heart rate 55
missing exercise dungey now 55 missing
as well and here is where it gets really
problematic so we have get slope you
have to run a nine missing so that's 30%
missing 33 percent fluoroscopy you have
to run a nine missing and to defect
you have almost half missing so forty
seven percent so that's where your
question comes in what do you do when
you have a variable and half of your
values are missing
so right now in this stage of our data
analysis we record all these things and
we save them for later basically so this
is it's important to record where do you
find missing values what percentage
you're represented out of your total
number of observations and then if you
decided to do anything about it already
or if you're going to keep them for
later and deal with them in the missing
data part of your report which is a
whole chapter by itself in cases like
this so what I decided to do here for
the purpose of the tutorial we we don't
have the time to get into this fully but
where we have 33 percent to 47 percent
of missing values I doubt you'll be able
to get much useful information out of
that we that you'll be able to correct
it without introducing your own biases
in it so I reduce the data set carrasco
P is a more invasive exam and that's why
it wasn't recorded probably many times
it wasn't done and in in this context is
you can't sort of fill it in at least
not quickly so that we can progress our
data set I decided to eliminate three
variables already the ones where you
have more than 33% of missing values and
then here what I did for the one that
rest ECG which has only 2% of missing
values I replaced it to the mode so
Fiona dia Fred I took the mode of that
variable you need to specify I log zero
because you can have several modes
that's that's like something like two
how pandas represent the mode and then
in place true
so here overall we just we replaced one
because we only have two percent of
missing values we're comfortable that
we're not introducing heavy biases into
our sample by replacing only two percent
to the mode of the series but we
couldn't do anything about the ones
where you have 33 to 47% of missing
values so what I wanted to see then and
this is literally how I started working
the data set from the beginning so I
wanted to see if I try to build a clean
data frame where I just take the parts
of each variable that are not know that
are not missing do I still have enough
observations to get an idea of it of
this data set about so
sometimes it's it's horrible right like
sometimes you you try to select the not
only the variables the observations or
you don't have any missing data and you
end up with zero lines in your in your
data frame here however you see I took
all the variables where we had missing
data so dear Fred recipe P not know and
the F right cholesterol not no idea Fred
fasting BS not no and yes max heart rate
not no guess exercise ng no not no and
yes I see depression not no and luckily
we realize that we still have 741
observations remaining so the clear
there is overlap between the different
variables but for this willing to start
to dig into it to see what was there
among the four centers we took remember
we uploaded four files was one of them
sloppier than the other ones why does
there seem to be so much overlap between
these different values and that's that's
that's a whole chapter by itself in
terms of missing data here so we can
progress i what i did i decided that
keeping 85% of our observations is
enough for our initial data exploration
so we have 741 clean observations no
missing data now we look at the whole
data frame just to check DF clean is no
any and we see that for every variable
it's false so those are 741 solid
observations I mentioned here I wanted
to explain so the the tubular notebook
that I uploaded is has a lot of
explanations in it and that's because
when I was going back years now when I
was migrating from r2 to pandas for
example you find a lot of amazing
tutorials you know when people are
presenting them really well but then we
need to take their notebooks and you
want to do it by yourself
you spend more time trying to understand
why they did something than how they did
it so I wanted to avoid that so I put a
lot of explanations across the notebook
so now that we clean the data we have a
data set of 741 observations that we can
work with and we can finally move on to
universe and Alice's
does everyone is from everyone familiar
with univariate analysis already so
universe because you start by looking at
each variable one at a time so that's
the first thing is to get a better idea
of each variable how is it distributed
what is it what does it tell you about
the observation your data set this is
part of descriptive statistics and here
you have the very important notions of
parameters and statistics so parameter
is calculated when you have the whole
population which you almost never do and
the statistic is something I calculate
from your sample about your parameter so
these are two terms that your you often
come across and in studying samples we
also make the assumption that the
central limit theorem holds so if you
draw in our friend examples from a
population and each sample is large
enough the distribution of the
statistics that you get from your
samples will follow the normal
distribution will be normally
distributed and the normal curve goes
back to getting beginning of the
eighteenth century
abraham de moivre but it's only it's
only in the late 19th century that
someone had the idea of starting to use
it as an ideal histogram so what do you
look for at this level at in terms of
descriptive statistics you look for
measures of center measures of spread
and measures of modality so what are the
measures of center to begin with this
you have three of them so there's the
mean there's the median and then there's
the mode then you look for symmetry or
skewness and this is the shape of your
distribution of your frequency
distribution
it could be unimodal it could be my mode
bimodal sometimes it's uniform and how
you look at it is going to be determined
by what type of variables you're working
with as we're going to see the rules
right here so we analyze the shape
visually by looking at the frequency
histogram then we check for measures of
center such as mean and median and then
we check for the spread so the spread is
expressed by the standard deviation
right what is the standard deviation
it's a measure that tells you how far
your observations are in average from
their mean in a normal distribution 68%
are within one standard deviation and
ninety-five percent are within two
standard deviations of your mean so
that's why you get a nice symmetric bell
shape for quantitative variables you
check the shape the center and the
spread and you use a histogram to
visualize them for categorical variables
you check you can only check the mode
because they don't have a mean right and
that has a lot of influence afterwards
for how we can visualize them and you
check you look
the mode and then you visualize them
with a bar chart or a frequency
distribution so to recap the rules for
visualizing data if you visualize one
variable at a time and it is categorical
you use a bar chart this is a SNSs count
plot function as we'll see if it is
quantitative we can combine a kernel
density estimate and a histogram with
the SNS this plot function as we'll draw
it right now as well and then for
visualizing two variables we'll get to
that input in the book by variety
analysis section let's start to gender
right let's get an idea of what what
these 741 observations we have how are
they distributed by gender so we use
them because it's a categorical variable
as we said with the SNS count that
function so here you see on the x-axis
you give you the explanatory variable
the variable of interest sex and then
you give it a data set theta equals DF
Queen so this is the data set you're
taking that variable from we give it a
title with a kiltie subtitle function
and here we see that there is a class
imbalance so you take note of this
so there's way more women in the study
than there are men will this have
implications this is where you're going
to start thinking about it what about
the diagnosis so this is the response
variable obviously we're doing this
whole thing to look at the response
variable and to try to predict it so
what how does it look
we have 0 1 2 3 & 4 so we see that
almost half of cases are 0 so they don't
have a pathology and then 1 2 3 & 4 are
different pathologies and we see that
27% of population is in the first one
and then 10% in 2 & 3 and only 2% in the
fourth one
what sort echos false tells your value
counts function is to not sort the
values by the most frequent one so to
leave them as they appear in the data
set in the order in which they appear in
the data set normalize equals true is an
attribute that tells value counts to
return to you the percentages instead of
the absolute counts then we visualize
the diagnosis with the count doc it's a
categorical variable as we said as well
and here we see that almost half our
interval in the neuropathology and then
we have 1 2 3 & 4 showing different
medical conditions
let's look at H now so H is different
right because H is quantitative so what
do you apply here well here you're
interested of within the mean the
standard deviation as we said the
minimum the maximum and for this we have
the describe function which is perfect
so we take the column EF clean edge
describe we see that we have the all the
741 observations we expected the mean is
53 years old the standard deviation for
this is nine point four the youngest
patient in the inter cohort was 28 years
old the oldest was 77 years old so the
ascendance despot combines the
matplotlib hist function with SNS KD
plot function we draw H as a
quantitative variable SNS this plot the
f queen age and then distribution of H
and here we see how its distributed so
here we have the VH and here we have the
distribution of patients in the study by
H and this what what shape does this
have sorry it looks it looks like a bell
curve but it's also unimodal basically
so it has one mode sometimes if we look
at it and it had two modes that would be
something we take note of as well but
it's unimodal now it's not a perfect
bell curve but it's not too distorted
either we look here was looking at the
other columns so again here we follow
literally how how I approached it when
preparing this then we look at VF Queen
max heart rate another quantitative
variable so this is the maximum heart
rate recorded for each patient we have
the full count again mean 138 standard
deviation 25 minimum is 60 and maximum
is 202 so here we see that we have a
wide range actually we plot it as well
with the despot function same for H and
we get this shape this figure
the plot that I really like the swarm
plot which is given by Seaborn so here I
plotted the diagnosis which you look at
before by accounts so here we have the
diagnosis and these these lines show you
about how many observations were wearing
each this one plot is a very useful
graph that Seabourn offers now that we
would looked at a couple of variables
we're not going to do it for each
variable but you would be expected
absolutely to do it for arrival in your
data set looked at each one of them
individually based on whether it's
quantitative or categorical and then
possibly also visualize it for yourself
and for the other people you work with
now we can move on to visualizing two
variables at a time so what are the
rules for two variables are you all
familiar with this so if one part if
your explanatory variable is categorical
and your response one is quantitative
you do it by variety bar graphs and you
use this and X Factor plot for this if
you have two quantitative variables use
a scatter plot and this is given to you
by the Seabourn right plot function and
then if you have what what do you do if
you have categorical to categorical how
do you guys plot that usually you could
but normally that you'd use that also
for a quantitative response variable on
the on the y axis the problem Y those
figures are not very meaningful for
categorical variables is that there's no
means basically so that's why you use no
matter how you watch shape you look at
rectangles no matter how you express
them the fact that you don't have a mean
to your categorical variable if you want
to put it on the y axis means that it
doesn't it doesn't mount to something
very meaningful also you do to buy to
basically yes absolutely that's one one
way of doing it that's a way of manually
going around it absolutely so we look at
sex versus age so SNS dr. plot here we
give it the X variable we give it a wide
variety equals bar and then that we
specify the data set give clean so we
see that the age is is almost the same
identical between men and women there's
no difference here
yes no I don't think that's the standard
deviation yes oh yes so someone is so
you're asking if there's a small bar
here on top is the standard deviation
I'm not sure actually we can we can look
into it so here we take something else
we take a gender versus blood pressure
at rest so here we have a positive
categorical variable on the x-axis and
then we have a quantitative on the
y-axis right so let's look at it as an X
Factor plot x equals x y equals R SVP
theta equals gf clean kind equals bar
and here we see that again there's
actually no difference so it seems that
gender doesn't influence to many of your
other variables in the data set seems
that men and women are pretty similar in
how they how they record these variables
what about two quantitative variables
now what would you use for that
so we said you're going to use the
direct log function from Seabourn and
here we have quantitative on the x axis
and quantity of on the y axis so SNS
right plot x equals h y equals
cholesterol let's check you know we are
as you get older does your cholesterol
level your Sturm cholesterol level go up
or not so that's what I want you to look
at we plot it and here we have H and we
have cholesterol and if anything it
looks like it's decreasing right which
is really weird but this is what the
data tells you I would have expected
line that slightly goes output it's not
the case here those are your data points
yes and you you this is your so what
rate flow does it plots your variables
basically your value or data points from
based on what you have on the x-axis and
what you have on the y-axis and the line
in the middle is the regression line so
the further a point is from that
regression line the more likely it is
that either that point or its errors
basically are are not explained by your
model
Oh oh you're you're looking at that we
absolutely we can remove them basically
no absolute and that's what we do this I
thought you were you're you're looking
for extreme outliers in the graph okay
absolutely
so in terms of to come back to the
categorical variables well how would you
be able to get a better idea of how two
categorical variables interact since you
can't really plot them the way that the
other types of rebels that we just
mentioned and one one thing is to group
your data set so it is a gift claim
group by gender here then I take the
diagnosis column and then I take the
value count and I divided by the length
of the full data frame so that it gives
me the percentage so here we have men on
top zero we have women here and then we
have the percentage of data set that
falls in each diagnosis by gender so
this is one way of manually getting
around the fact that you can't plot them
in another way if you want to get a
better idea of how two categorical
variables interact grouping by one of
them and then taking the value counts or
the percentages like here of the other
is one way of trying to get around it
and getting a better idea of how your
data set is distributed versus those two
categorical variables then you have the
boxplot function so SNS box plots
cholesterol on the on the y-axis gender
on the on the y-axis data equals DF
claim so here we have the extreme
outliers and again this is one way of
getting around the fact that you want to
what you want to measure cholesterol by
sex it's another way of visualizing
basically we would have put cholesterol
in the y-axis like we did before here we
decided to draw the box plots which is a
common statistical figure and the
perhaps one of the most important
functions that fathers offers you is
that you can group by your whole data
frame by a variable of interest here
diagnosis that's what we're trying to to
predict for and you can describe it and
what describe does is going to take away
your categorical variables again they
have known me
you cannot calculate measures like the
mean for them but it's going to take all
the quantitative ones and it's going to
give you the key statistics for all of
them by the variable that interests you
the most so here is diagnosis we have
the folder category 0 1 2 3 4 and then
we have h we have cholesterol we have
max heart rate we have raised P P and we
have STD / depression and we have the
mean we have the minimum the maximum we
have the quartile splits and the count
that falls in each of them so this is a
way of getting an overall overview of
your whole dataset at once
now before before starting until now we
just observe the data set we described
it we didn't beyond the initial data
management we didn't manipulate the data
set so the idea is once you start
manipulating the data set manipulative
variables it's good to make a copy so DF
clean copy equals GS clean dot copy so
we don't work with the original data set
that we cleaned we keep that aside and
from now on we work with a copy of the
data set and now we move to to
inferential statistics so until now use
descriptive statistics now we finally
get into the inferential statistics part
anyone why is it called inferential
statistics here because using your
sample to infer statistics parameters of
about the whole population right
absolutely
and what are the steps that you always
take that is at this level in our in
your data like in your process what do
you start with exactly exactly so you
start by making a hypothesis based on
what interests you and every time you
have the null hypothesis right and then
you have h1 there are 25 proteases and
you try to see if your data from your
sample Baxter alternative hypothesis or
not so the process you define the null
hypothesis and the alternative
hypothesis you should you choose the
sample which here we have we've already
done we analyze the evidence based on
the statistical tests that we're going
to be using and then again we interpret
the results
typical null hypothesis is that there is
no relationship the two varieties
you're looking at our independent
typical alternative hypothesis there is
a distancing interrelationship between
your two variables now the Viper is
disco tools that we use so when we look
when we test to two variables one
against the other what do we use there's
there's three main ones right so there's
ANOVA there's chi-square and then
there's the correlation coefficient
anyone knows the difference
you
they all make assumptions that's the
thing about statistical tools each one
makes its own assumptions and the way
you're going to be using them it comes
partly from the data you have and partly
from your knowledge of these assumptions
you're absolutely right though in some
of the differences you make but it's the
type of variable again that's going to
determine which one of these three tools
we're going we're going to be using to
test for independence or not so what are
the key here the key idea is that a
result is statistically significant if
it is unlikely to be the result of
chance so we take the problem a bit
gather way around because this is the
best we have
so you state the null hypothesis so you
suspect there's a relationship between
two variables but you first state a new
hypothesis and you say look there's no
relationship and then you look at what
the data tells you and the way you're
accepting your alternative hypotheses
your h1 is that you're saying how
unlikely would it be to see this data to
see the statistics in my sample if the
null hypothesis was true that's that's
the underlying logical reasoning behind
all three tests then we're going to
check the p-value want to look at the
first ANOVA table we're going to check
the F statistic as well and then I
mentioned here again that before using
any of these analysis you need to use
the jötnar function so to drop all your
null values because they all assume
perfect information here we clean the
data set we we kept only 741
observations of 920 but you wouldn't be
able to use these functions with no
values so let's let's test the idea that
agent diagnoses are not related right so
as I was saying is the type of variables
that you have that will determine which
one of these three tests you're going to
be using so if you have an explanatory
categorical a categorical explanatory
variable and a quantitative response
variable you use an ANOVA table if you
have an explanatory categorical variable
and then a response categorical variable
you use the chi-square test the
chi-square test as you were saying
actually implies the different
distribution and what it does it implies
that your options your outcome options
amount to one
that the whole probability universe from
zero to one is covered but the the
choices you have the categories you have
that's why it is for categorical data
then if you have an explanatory a
quantitative variable and the response
categorical variable what you need to do
is you need to bring your explanatory
quantitative variable and then you need
to use the same thing as the previous
line the chi-square test so categorical
categorical chi-square test and the last
one explanatory quantitative variable
and response quantifiable use the person
correlation which spreads the most
straightforward one so here as you saw
in the data set what the data set what
our response variable is is the
diagnosis right 0 1 2 3 4 but what we're
doing here with this stats model is that
we're putting the age as the response
variable and I wanted to ask you it is
this completely wrong to you
like we're turning the problem on its
head right is it something you're
allowed to do or not so we are being a
bit naughty but we're not overly not in
the sense that it's something that you
are allowed to do so you're allowed to
to invert your x and y in your analysis
and this is why you can never imply
causation because the direction you can
you can change the direction between the
two variables
what you have is correlation but you
never can prove causation with these
types of methods so that's why actually
we could we can very well try to use
diagnosis to predict age based on our
data set and this is also the reason why
we won't be able to say this causes this
but only that they are associated in one
way or another
so here we have the SMS OLS model so SMS
ALS and then we give the formula for the
model in parentheses formula equals here
age response variable then the tilde and
then diagnosis and the C tells you tells
test models that this is a categorical
variable we specify the data set data
equals gift clean copy and then we fit
it and then we print the the summary so
Oh
effect okay
so this is what what your first anova
table looks like so you get your list
regression results right and then we
look at the variable that with an
explanatory variable so the C diagnosis
and we have the t1 t2 t3 and t4 with the
t0 becoming the baseline and the most
important parts for us here are the
coefficients that our linear regression
model comes up with and then the P
statistic associated us coefficients so
what we what we see is that we have an
intercept of 50 so that's what we start
with the explanatory variable being 0
and then 50 being an H here and then how
does it progress by type of diagnosis
that you have basically by type of
categorical explanatory variable so from
the p-value we see that they are
significant so you'd be able to say that
this is this extra variable are
significant in helping you determine
people's age and here we have the
assumption that the model makes standard
errors assume that the covariance matrix
of the errors is correctly specified
every time before we go into the first
post hoc test is it ok if we take a 5 10
minute break now we're almost halfway
through basically and from now on it's
going to be linear regression and
logistic regression okay or I'll be here
at please tell me something like clear
comes to me and I'm perfectly available
obviously we look at the first ANOVA
table right and what do we see we see a
among others right we see the R squared
statistic we see a net statistics right
here we see the p-value associated yes
statistic so before we even move on
let's discuss this what is the who can
give me a definition of what the S value
stands for how it's calculated basically
what is it okay so so if the variation
among sample means divided by the
variation within samples why is this
important is because we're trying to
show that the groups are looking at are
not independent
right so that's why if you look at the
variation among sample means basically
so between samples divided by the
variation within each sample which you
may call the more natural variation this
is a anova f-test this what it gives you
and this follows a sort of statistical
distribution which you can read by
taking the 28 point 42 F statistic and
is that number that also is going to be
linked to the p-value that's right under
it what matters the most to us here is
obviously the fact that the p-value
shows that it's highly significant right
I mean we have 5.56 eat 2 to the power
of minus 22
so we move 21:02 to the left right now
in the number so we're way below 0.05
which is usual limit we take which by
the way we that's a historical practice
basically there's a lot of the debate
right now about why is it 0.05 why would
you reject the study if you're at 0.06
how much data wrangling let's say goes
into making sure your p-value is going
to be below 0.05 so it's there's no
solid basis beyond that it's a
convention that we've adopted a long
time ago already and that we're still
still applying so we have our F
statistic here and we have our p-value
here this is the key in the ANOVA table
and then we see that for every every
level of our explanatory variable in
this case diagnosis it gives us a
coefficient and then an Associated
p-value which takes us tells us if that
is a significant or not
and we have a confidence interval for it
as well so in or 95% confident that the
the value for diagnostic group 1 for
example is going to be between one point
one three four and four point one five
three while the average gives us here is
two point 64 what happens now is that
our explanatory variable has more than
two levels right so we'll whenever your
explanatory categorical variable has
more than two levels you need to also
perform post hoc statistical tests why
is that because you want to better
understand the relationship between your
response to a categorical variable and
you want to make sure that what you know
now is that your groups are different so
your rejected your null hypothesis based
on your p-value but you don't know how
they are different
maybe because you have several groups
several levels of your categoricals
arrival maybe for example diagnostic
group three and four are actually the
same so for them the null hypothesis
holds they are not they are not
different
maybe you rejected it because your group
one is so different from your group for
that
that's what what's causing your
statistical power in the test but then
you want to look at every groups you
want to associate each two groups one
against each other
to make sure that you are not rejecting
the null hypothesis when it's actually
true in part of your analysis yes please
oh yes because what happens is that we
specified it's a categorical variable
for stats models so it immediately
decided that the first one zero is there
is your base variable so it holds that
one you read this by saying compared to
t0 t1 has a coefficient of 2 point 64
basically and you'd multiply that by
your observation so it sets for
categorical variables you're typically
looking at n minus 1 when you're
analyzing them so here something we can
do already is to look at the the means
of the different groups so let's see
let's take each diagnostic diagnostic
group and let's look at what the mean
age for that group is so we have 0 it's
51 is 52 2 is 58 a 4 is 59 then we can
look at the standard deviation as well
to see if those differences in means are
large enough this is very heuristic we
see 9 8 7 we can really make up our mind
here we can really decide something so
there are several tests that allow you
to take a much better approach here one
is the talkee HSD test another one is
the home t-test and then another one is
the least significant difference and
then you have Shaffer and a couple of
other ones as well the code for a Tukey
HSD test is this one so we create an
object to k1 multi-touch multi
comparison we take the two series within
the data frame that we're trying to
compare DF clean copy age and yet clean
copy diagnosis then
we create the res one as an object and
then we take its summary which gives you
actually the trkage is these summary
statistics itself so this is the the
code here and what we see here is that
it takes every two diagnostic groups and
then it compares them in terms of age to
try to see if they're significant so
that's a way we said we know that we
accepted that diagnostic group can help
us predict age but then we don't know
why is it because groups 0 and 1 for
example are very different but groups 3
& 4 are the same and what this is what
this type of of post hoc statistical
test does does for you so here we see
web group 1 we have group 2 so it
compares them two at a time right
pairwise comparison it gives you their
mean difference it gives you the lower
and upper bounds and then in the reject
column it tells you if if your
alternative hypothesis is true or not
basically so if you should reject your
null hypothesis or not and what we see
for example is that for the last three
ones so groups 2 versus 3 group 2 vs. 4
and group 3 versus 4 by age are you here
we cannot reject the null hypothesis
actually so we wrongly rejected the null
hypothesis before for the whole study as
a whole but actually if you drill down
into the detail you realize that here we
cannot and whenever you you cannot
reject your null hypothesis you also see
that in your lower and upper bound for
your coefficient include 0 basically so
if you're also going to go from minus to
plus something here and that's why it's
possible that is 0 that actually there's
no difference between them so let's just
another hypothesis now so let's decide
that we want to see if the presence of
chest pain is indicated or third of the
diagnostic state of someone I mean you'd
expect that chest pain would would
contribute to to predicting if if
they're healthy or if they have a hard
pathology right so our alternative
hypothesis here is the presence of chest
pain and diagnosis are not independent
here I put an aside about feature
engineering because is the first time
that we manipulate the feature itself
here is going to be the response
variable we're going to recode it
actually we're going to
a multi-level variable into a binary one
but it's a discussion of feature
engineering and how important it
actually is but this is something that
obviously would follow I would come into
the middle of your study not in your
first initial data exploratory part I
also put some links here to some very
good articles on this so the first one
explains its really well and the second
one Trevor Stevens applies it in the
case of the Titanic the kaggle Titanic
data set which many of you are familiar
with I imagine and that's where you see
just how this engineered features
regularly end up actually become the
most important features in your models
what we're doing here is we're taking
we're recording our response variable so
we have four levels now right of zero
one two three four but ultimately what
we're interested in is just is the
patient healthy or not like do they have
a heart pathology or not so we're going
to turn to into a binary variable with
the we create a dictionary and then we
map that dictionary on tour of times on
our series we see that the result is
that 384 patients had a pathology and
then 257 didn't and now we're looking at
two categorical variables right you have
a diagnosis which is binary and you have
chest pain which has four levels I
believe yes four levels so what do you
do here it's here you can't use an ANOVA
table again so it's here that you start
using the chi-square which is suitable
for categorical to categorical what you
do is that you create you first create a
contingency table and you always put the
the response variable first so the
response variable is vertical and then
the explanatory one is horizontal so
here we have diagnosis 0 1 and we have
chest plain 1 2 3 4 and the PD crosstab
function allows us we says we give it
the two series from our data frame and
it allows us to show how many how many
values how many observations fall into
each group so healthy and chest pain one
healthy and chest pain 2 etc basically
then what what I'm doing afterwards in
the column percentages
I'm simply converting this into a
percentage basically 4 column
so 23 and 15 or 128 and 22 this gives
you a more readable version of the same
cross-table and then you move on to the
chi-square test so look at what the
chi-square test does it actually
recreates a column a table like this
like the one you have on top there and
it creates it with the assumption that
the two variables are independent so it
looks at how many observations should
fall into every every of the eight boxes
we have there let's say if the two
variables are independent then it looks
at what you actually have in our data
set and then as usual with statistical
tests at this level it come it decides
how likely would we be to see what we
see in the data set versus what we would
have this if the two that were
completely independent so print this is
simply for us for readability we say
print the chi-square value the p-value
and the expected counts and then we
create the object cs1 scifi that stats
by chi tune so chi squared contingency
and we give it the the table that we
created above here and then it gives us
the chi-square value which is the result
of the chi-square distribution and then
it gives us the Associated p-values if
it's significant or not so as you see
were way below 0.05 so we can consider
that it's it's significant and here we
have the expected counts in parentheses
actually which is what would have been
expected if the two variables were
independent here you have the same
problem right I mean you we have an
explanatory variable with multiple
categories so again right now we reject
the null hypothesis but we don't know
exactly why we don't know how those
different groups of the explanatory
variable are behaving so you'd perform
something very similar to what we did
before but here it's called the
bonferroni adjustment so basically you
adjust your p-value by the number of
pairwise comparisons that you'd be doing
between your categorical and your
response variable so you significantly
diminish your p-value actually and then
you perform those pairwise comparisons
or a group of explanatory variable and
then you look which two groups based on
your adjusted p-value
you can reject the null hypothesis
versus you cannot just as we did before
but it's a different type of method
because we're dealing with a chi-square
test and categorical variables here
let's look at our columns basically to
see if there's something else we'd like
to check so here I'm looking at whether
a gender is associated with the
diagnosis are women more likely or less
likely for example than men to have a
heart pathology or not in this data set
we create the PD crosstab as before we
look at the column percentages as before
and then we run the chi-square test and
the chi-square test once more it has a
value of 65 which you can read using the
distribution and then it has a very low
p-value so arguably gender is also
significant in predicting the diagnostic
group of someone something that I wanted
us to touch on up and here is moderators
so what our moderators a moderator is
any third variable that significantly
affects the direction or the strength of
the relationship you found basically so
that's this is one of the main reasons
why you can only talk about correlation
and not causation because sometimes two
variables are very closely associated a
very common example that's given is how
stirrup is basically how large a fire is
versus how many fighters of the
firefighters are there so these two are
very correlated with each other but you
cannot deduct a causation between them
right it would be wrong to say that more
firefighters cause a bigger fire which
is what your data would be telling you
basically obviously this is what a
moderator comes in that's what the third
variable is you call the moderator
variables lurking variables or
confounding variables all these terms
are used in the literature and what that
does in our case you'd be the
seriousness of the fire so is the
seriousness of the fire that determines
how big the fire is and how many
firefighters are there although the two
are seem correlated at first and you
deep keen but wrong to deduce a
causation so how do you how do you check
for a moderator how do you check whether
a third variable is a moderator in in
the relationship that you just found
what you need to do is you need to take
your data set and you need to split it
by values of that third variable and you
need to see if your if your statistical
significant relationship between your
explanatory and your response variable
holds for each level of the third
variable if it holds for each level it
means that it's significant in the
presence of the third variable and that
is not a moderating variable if however
you find that it doesn't that doesn't
hold for some level then that third
variable moderates the relationship
between your explanatory and your
response variable in this case so here
it's very simple because we're looking
we're wondering whether gender is a
moderator in the statistically
significant relationship that we just
found between chest pain and diagnostic
group so what we need to do is when you
stick our data frame and then we need to
divide it by gender as we said there's
two groups in our hypothetical moderator
variable right there zero which is men
and then there's one which is women and
again we see that there's much more
women in the study than than men and
what we need to do now is that we need
to run a chi-square test for each of the
two new data frames that we cost we
created so we need to see if chest pain
is related with a diagnostic group for
both men and women and if it is we can
see that gender is not a moderator
variable in this relationship if it's
not then gender is we have a
relationship that is significant for
women but not for men or vice versa so
we run the chi-square tests as we did
before and here for example the first
one we started with is men so we see
that for men we have a chi-square
statistic of 39 and then a very low
associate p-value so again we can say
that it's the relationship holds between
chest pain and diagnostic group for men
now does it hold for women as well now
we're taking our data frame for women
give clean copy women diagnosis binary
and DF clean copy women chest pain and
let's see if it holds for women as well
here we end up with a much larger
chi-square value and then a very small
p-value as well way smaller than 0.05 so
we can see that the relationship is
significant
for women as well so we can conclude
that gender is not a moderator variable
but that's how you test for a moderate
variable you need to divide your data
set by by levels of that hypothetical
moderator variable and need to see if
the relationship that is two takes a
significant that you found holds for
each level of that third variable yes
please yes yes I so that's what I was
trying to say before that we as a
historical practice in statistics we use
0.05 at the thresholds level so if your
p-value is smaller than 0.05 you can you
can see that it's very significant Oh in
that case no you wouldn't like for
example when values are below 0.001 you
just you don't even record them it just
says the p-value below 0.01 that's just
a value that lets you tell tells you if
you're a statistic or chi-square
statistic in this case is significant or
not for the type of data that you're
observing basically you mean to get the
chi-square statistic no because there's
they're both so small that yes again
when you have p value is below 0.001 in
studies i usually they don't even record
the value like now here they would just
say we found the p value below 0.001 for
example at their discretion you know i
was just trying to get a better idea of
diagnosis by chest pain by grouping the
data frame by type of by level of chest
sign basically and looking at the
diagnostic levels and here we conclude
that the relationship between chest pain
and diagnostic category holds for both
levels of the gender variable and
therefore it's not a moderated
variable here something else is is that
in case we had found that gender is a
moderating variable we would still not
be able to imply causation you just get
a bit closer to the truth to the true
causation but we would certainly not be
able to imply causation here either yes
you'd be able yes
yes because they'll tell you and that's
why when you when you do multi Verret
regression you add with the variables
one by one ideally right so that you see
if how they change sometimes you have a
variable and then it turns out that
another variable you already had becomes
insignificant for example that's why you
add them one by one to see how they
interact with each other and with the
variables you already have in your
statistical model so here I was just
putting the note that when two variables
are correlated so when we find a
statistically significant relationship
it's possible that X causes Y or Y
causes X or Z causes both x and y
basically and it's also possible that
they call it by chance which is what we
call a spurious correlation here I was
looking at h and cholesterol so draw the
the direct plot we spoke about this
before we see that the regression line
slightly descends by H actually and then
here is an expression of your equation
so when you have a quantitative
explanatory variable in quantitative
response variable perhaps that's where
the or coefficient this is that s that's
easiest and most familiar to most to
everyone it's a statistic that can go
between minus 1 and 1
it measures association or causation as
all of them and then it's a it's a
number that tells you how strong the
your correlation is between the two
variables and if it is basically so
let's let's check it here print
association between agent cholesterol
right that's what we said we're looking
at and then we take the SyFy stats
pearson are statistics so this is what
we most frequently refer to as our
as the correlation coefficient so we
give it the gift clean copy H and EF
clean copy cholesterol and this is the
art expand it the correlation
coefficient it sounds minus 0.06 that's
what drives the the slope slightly down
and then look at the p-value for example
it's 0.06 so in this case we say we
cannot project the null hypothesis so it
would appear that agent cholesterol are
independent of each other which is
supported by the right plot why it's
important to always draw red plots with
quantitative variables yes you can you
can it's one of those things that you
can only practice very close by but you
can never get right there the only way
you can establish causation is it in a
true experiment so that's why if you go
back to the definition of a true
experiment it's something where you
control all variables except for one
which you modify yourselves basically
and with observations assign random
links to the two groups in the India
experiment and that's the closest you'll
ever get to the causation pretty much
the reason it's always important to draw
a record for quanta variables though
saying is that sometimes the the
correlation coefficient only measures
linear Association so sometimes it's
possible that you're going to see a very
good polynomial Association but if your
our coefficients gonna tell you the two
variables are not associated at all with
each other but when you draw the right
plot then you find a nice of sinusoidal
curve for example and then you realize
that there is a relationship there but
it's just polynomial nonlinear and you
the correlation coefficient missus is
completely so it's awesome advice to
always draw rect plus as well and here
we are we have linear regression so and
logistic regression and these are the
last two things I wanted us to see today
again I put here a lot of explanations
around what are their assumptions as we
said you always make assumptions so you
have independence you have linearity you
have normality it's you're always making
assumptions basically and here I said
we're going to create a multiple
regression model
and we're going to investigate a
relation between our explanatory
variables and then our response the
variable diagnosis so here you have
categorical variables and Kant
quantitative variables I divided them
into and you'll see just now why before
you get into multi linear regression
it's a good practice to recode your
variables you need to Center your
quantitative variables and then you need
to make sure that your categorical
variables have a value of zero at some
point in them basically so that's one of
the groups of your categorical variable
gets coded as zero why this is this is
simply for us for interpretability
basically this because this is how
you're you when you Center variables
you're basically holding them constant
at zero you'll see just now in the in
the in the ANOVA table so how do we do
this we look at chest pain for example
and we see that we don't have 0 so we
need to recode I recorded the 1 to 0 the
2 to 1 and so on and then you use the
map function to record it here fasting
blood sugar we have a 0 variable already
rest ECG we have a 0 1 so we're fine
exercise on Gina we have 0 already and
now we move to the quantity variables
which we need to Center and the way you
Center quantity variables is that you
take your series and you subtract the
mean of the series from every value
that's what's going to Center is
basically so in total what this means is
that your series is going to have a mean
of 0 then I look at all the columns we
just we just created quite a few new
variables so I'm listing all of them
here and then I call the new data frame
will be using DF clean copy see see for
centered and here we only take the
variables that we just centered or that
we just recode it for the categorical
ones so we end up with this data frame
we have H centered we have gender we
have a chest pain we have red blood
pressure cholesterol centered so all the
quantitive variables have a seat they're
centered and the categorical ones have
been recorded if needed
and here we start to run the linear
regression model so we look at whether
sex is a good predictor of age for
example in our in our data set we find
an F statistic of 0.8 very low a
statistic and then we have a we find the
probability so an associated p value of
0.3 which is way higher than 0.05 so we
can reject this relationship and then
this is the approach you take as we were
just saying before right now so you add
one variable one variable at a time and
you see what influence that has on the
statistics you just had before so model
do we create a new object and here we
try to see whether sex and cholesterol
have statistical other statistically
significant association with age what do
we find here we 5 on our square root of
0.005 only the r-squared if anyone
doesn't know it's a wave of explaining
to you how much of the variability in
your data is explained by the model you
currently have
so here it's the 0.5% it's almost
nothing basically so sex and cholesterol
don't help us predict H almost at all
again we have a non significant p-value
0.15 2 and here we find individual
coefficients and again you see that
they're not significant but based on
their p-value here but at the same time
the confidence interval includes zero as
we said and here I created a full model
write model 3 SMS OLS formula age and
let's use all the all the variables we
have to help us predict age and then we
signify when they're categorical so
chest pain is categorical rest ECG is
categorical and then let's let's fit the
model here and let's look at the summary
statistics so here we have an r-squared
that moved up to 0.278 right so we will
explain almost 30% of the variability in
age with the variables we just included
in our models so from our data set and
we have this time when a statistic of 21
and a p-value that is a very significant
at 1.25 a minus 43 basically so again
you move 42 bad 42 zeros to the left so
you're way below 0.05
and the table gives us the Associated
coefficients for every level of our
categorical variables and for every
quantitative variable as well and this
is how you build your model about y
equals you know this sort this whole
model basically the intercept plus each
value that you find here four
coefficients multiplied by the number of
those observations let's look at the
p-values here so we see that the first
group of testing does has any
significant p-value we see that the
second one does the same the third one
as well so here these already Creek with
three variables that we can exclude from
our data set basically they don't help
us predict H actually here we for this
this variable the coefficient is not
meaningful and here I was saying that's
okay so we managed to explain 30% of the
variability in H right but let's let's
run some Diagnostics now and these are
diagnostic you can always run for linear
regression let's run a QQ plot for
normality for example so we create a fig
one and then from stats models we use
the QQ plot function and then we look at
the residuals so what you find here is
that our the the residuals of our model
are actually very close to the red line
which which is the ideal line so that's
then if your residuals are normally
distributed which is one of the
assumptions we're making when using
these models your blue dots which are
your actual residuals are going to
follow the red line very closely and
here you see that they do so you don't
get we don't have problems of we don't
need to suspect that the relationship is
actually highly nonlinear or something
like that then I draw the residuals here
so these are the Pearson residuals and
what this allows you to do is that these
standardized is all your residuals so
allows you to see how they're
distributed and what you see what you'd
love is for them to be as close to the
zero line as possible which means that
they're very small here you see that you
have quite a few between two and three
standard deviations that's what the
y-axis shows you and you have quite a
few actually for one you have a couple
that are above three as well so the the
problem here is what this tells us is
that our model is not very good at
explain
the variability in our response variable
which is what we knew from the R squared
as well we can only explain 30% and
that's what you see in the residuals as
well
and a last diagnostic that you can apply
to linear regression is the leverage
plot what the leverage plot allows you
to see if there's any if there's any
points in your data set that
significantly modify your your model
basically so here we'd have to go to the
two point number 33 index 33 and figure
out it's a high leverage point and it's
also for close to two standard
deviations away from our mean basically
so this is the point I would have to
investigate because it's significantly
impacts our model sometimes you find a
lot of points like this I need to go
look for each of them basically yeah
leverage is that's a measure of how
important that one point is in your
model basically how much modifies your
model so it's like what what you look at
this graph is how how far away from zero
the residuals are and then leverage
tells you how important they are what
impact they have in your model basically
so because if they're far away from the
mean button they don't have an impact on
your model for one reason or another you
don't need to worry about them so much
but if they're both far away from zero
and then they're they have a high impact
on your model leverage means impact here
then you need to investigate them
because they significantly impact the
results of your model it so it's a way
of looking for residuals basically and
trying to it's a it's you take the
problem get away around you look at the
residuals of your linear regression
model and then you try to figure out
what causes those standard errors
basically those residuals to be so high
yes yeah you need to go look at that
observation and try to figure out
whether it was a miss miss recorded for
example whether it is a good reason for
it to be there it's basically something
that tells you go to your data set and
then look for this specific point yes
decide decide if it makes sense to keep
it or not basically because it's
significally impacts your model in any
case
and here we're getting close to the end
I wanted us to finally go to our actual
response variable which is a diagnosis
binary as we coded it and because we
have a categorical response variable we
don't use the linear regression model
right we use a logistic regression model
here and here we use the SMS logit model
so the formula we give a diagnosis
binary as a variable of chest pain
basically and it's it's very similar to
the way you analyze it for for linear
regression let me see where we have the
full model yeah so this is the the the
analysis of the full model basically for
the diagnostic binary variable response
variable so here we have all the
variables we gave it you see that you
have several whenever you it's
categorical and then you have the
associate coefficients the p-values like
before and then the confidence intervals
like before as well basically what you
do find however is that for logistic
regression it makes more sense to talk
about odds ratios than about
coefficients so rather than look at the
coefficients in the previous table we
calculate the odds ratios here so NP
xlr8 3 and we take the params basically
and whenever a an odds ratio is higher
than 1 you say you can say basically
that for example here the for the
categorical sex variable if you're
looking at at the first group so at a
woman they have you'd have a 3.7 times
more chances of having a diagnostic
binary value of 1 basically so having a
heart
pathology assuming you hold all the
other variables constant and you really
read like this each each excitatory
variable in your logistic regression
model through the odds ratio so it tells
you then how how much more likely you
are to fall in the in the level 1 of
your response variable assuming you hold
all the other things constant in your
model
here we calculate the confidence
intervals and I see we're way past but I
wanted to tell you there's a there's
quite a bit more here and it's done on
purpose we weren't meant to go through
all of it but again it's something that
I wanted people to be able to take with
them and to play around with it and to
consider it think rate adjust it improve
it as a blueprint of how you start to
look at the data set there's a amusing
decision trees and random forests a bit
later in this in this notebook to look
more at the model and to try to come up
with a better predictive model basically
with the higher accuracy and also to
look at features that I would actually
keep in the end as far as the feature
engineering part of the of the process
so the the notebook doesn't end here
it's all public please don't hesitate to
use it and please email me if you have
any questions if you want to discuss
something if you want to work on it or
this is anything I can assist you with
thank you all for your time and I'm
around
you